hey youtubers this Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
the flash season 2 arrow season 4
Supergirl legends of tomorrow there was
a little extra news like there's a big
you know WTF Supergirl thing that
happened yesterday obviously I can't do
any videos for that show till they air
it publicly so I hope you guys
understand um you know I'm not trying to
accord any big lawsuits from Warner
Brothers television since we have
finished air on the flash I'm actually
kind of curious let me know which of you
guys waited to watch the flash or arrow
like any of those shows till after they
were finished like maybe you're in
school like you were waiting till after
you were done I always get a lot of
questions where people ask if you have
to watch the flash to understand what's
going on on arrow and vice-versa and
that's never the case like they always
have their own narratives the crossovers
you usually end up being like really
small one-off things even with legends
of tomorrow building on both shows you
know that's not gonna change next year
but I do think it helps if you watch all
these shows just for extra context it
just makes it a little bit more fun if
you guys are looking for like a really
fun DC comic to read this summer Geoff
Johns is writing darkside Ward that's a
Justice League title it's part of the
Justice League ongoing series he's doing
something really awesome with the
mythology of the anti-monitor that's all
I'll say
on to questions here we go baby and asks
do you think that mainstream audiences
will be able to take in all the
multiverse stuff or will the ratings
fall for season two so you're talking
about the flash well no I you know the
shows are made so that they're really
easy to follow for people that don't
recom --ax in terms of level of
difficulty I think the flash will be
much easier to follow than say a show
like Doctor Who that gets really timeyou
why me with its logic there will be a
lot of awesome comic book moments but
but generally the writers try to make
the plot flow organically from where the
characters are and what they're doing
they also do a really good job of giving
Cisco those explainer moments where he's
like oh you know Back to the Future
rules oh uh you know terminator rules
like whenever they were making jokes
about time-travel the way I think about
the flash is it's a show designed for
someone like me to enjoy but did someone
like my mom could follow and just in
general if you're ever wondering like
where each of the show's draws from in
the comics the flash generally draws
from Geoff Johns era that's like Wally
West's era arrows a little bit more
general it's not quite as tied to the
comic books as the flashes so it draws
from all over the place Justice League
stories Green Arrow stories Batman
stories all over the place let
tomorrow's kind of a blend between
Justice Society Justice League and the
time masters the limited rip hunter
series Supergirl will treat comic-book
stuff I think the same way arrow does it
there will be comic book things but it
but it'll change some of the backstories
like in the way arrow has played with
the Merlin character notable character
from the comics but one that's a little
underserved
so arrow just brought him to the
forefront a lot more because they got
John Barrowman next question Jordan asks
does that symbol on Eddie's necklace
look like the Captain Atom symbol
there's all there are so many people
wondering what Eddie has around his neck
a lot of people thought it might be the
reverse flash ring I don't think it's
that I do think that it's just some sort
of talisman a lot of people think that
it might be a reference to cobalt blues
talisman because his name is Malcolm
Thawne he was a notable reverse-flash
that was part of the Thawne family I
said in my flash season 2 video Eddie
will be back as a guest star let you
know we have no idea how that's going to
happen or if they'll take him in a
cobalt blue direction but it's totally
possible usually the writers draw from
Geoff Johns hair in the comics Malcolm
Thawne isn't part of that but Andrew
Kreisberg the executive producer in the
showrunner he's the one that wrote this
episode and he is a comic book expert on
the level of Geoff Johns he even wrote
the Green Arrow comic book for a while
so he could have made the executive
decision being the most powerful person
on the show to include that little
Easter Egg they wouldn't have shown it
on screen if it wasn't important
anything that appears on screen is
relevant like there are no accidents
like they don't accidentally put
something in a scene next question the
Batman lover asks I think it's season 2
Barry will be trying to find his way
home
phasing through different universes of
course yeah I mean he flew right up into
that vortex so he's gonna see a bunch of
other stuff if not actually going into
those other realities I don't think
they're gonna go too hardcore into
jumping between universes because for
the most part we'll be following the
people we saw on the ground like that
group of people when we get multiverse
stuff I think it's going to be
multiverse spilling into our timeline it
can get a little confusing when you
think about the differences between the
multiverse and the comics like the DC
multiverse and the idea of different
timelines because those are two
different ideas I think the show will
introduce the idea of the multiverse but
I think their version of it will be a
little more logical than the comic book
version what you'll have is like a
fringe situation where there's alternate
timelines that represent alternate
reality
at the same time you'll have just like
straight-up time travel where berries
traveling along his past present and
future then you have Cisco with his vibe
powers sensing alternate timelines
alternate realities I'm trying not to
theorycraft
too much you know about the way they're
gonna do this because you can get really
timey wimey with the way they explain it
but I'm thinking of it more in a fringe
context next question though Phillip
asks I know I'm reaching but wouldn't it
be cool if one of the earths that we saw
was from Smallville like one of the
alternate realities well the people that
made Smallville that's a completely
different group of people than the
people that are making air on the flash
so I'm not expecting a whole lot of that
I know there's a lot of rumors about Tom
Welling making a cameo that there's
still like at the rumor level that that
hasn't been confirmed by anyone but I
think that most we can expect you know
from Smallville stuff is them just like
say making a joke about Oliver never
going sleeveless little fun stuff like
that next question sex ops asks what
happened to the Gideon computer did you
Bart take her or if she's still there
I'm assuming that he took her I know you
will find out in episode 1 of season 2
the Gideon computer is a little bit like
Fury's toolbox on agents of shield you
can see how it'd be a good source for
stories but it would be a way to
overpower team flash and I think they
want to try and avoid that
next question John asks who is white
canary so she's like very different from
what the caity lotz character is gonna
be in the comics she is one of 12
children born to this martial artist
called Sifu seafood was this really
legendary figure that wanted to pass on
his knowledge to 12 children each of the
children were born to different women
under a different sign of the zodiac
he was intended that they all be male
like any of them that were born female
were killed off with the exception of
canary they were dubbed the twelve
brothers of the Silk and eventually
white canary took them down but
initially white canary showed up as a
villain in the birds of prey comic she's
actually like a really minor character
so I don't fault legends or tomorrow for
changing the backstory the TV shows
already explained the differences you
know she's Sarah Lance resurrected in
the Lazarus Pit who takes a new identity
next question all he asks how do you
think that they'll explain hawkgirl's
backstory well I think it'll be pretty
close to the comic book origin story in
the trailer they kind of address it you
know the the reincarnation aspect of her
character I think that they'll just
stick with that
but they won't show it on screen the
other characters will just find it
dubious Marc Guggenheim did say that
they would start playing with magic in
the aro universe because of the Vixen
digital series we also have the Lazarus
Pit they're calling that a magical
device so so there is magic so
reincarnation isn't too hard to swallow
in terms of the way her wings work I
think it'll be a harness just like it is
in the comic books it just seems like
that would be the more practical
approach to it it'd be way more
expensive to do it all CG it'll probably
end up happening is they'll do her wings
as like a combination of practical and
CG just to make them a little more
spectacular next question cmx
wheel legends of tomorrow have a season
two I thought it was a one-off thing
like roots or taken I like I like that
you mentioned roots which is like
totally not a comic book II thing yeah
the idea is is that it's developed as a
series it'll go on as long as the CW
picks it up it'll probably end up
happening is is that they'll just have
like a different reason for the team-up
every year it's not gonna be Vandal
Savage coming back every year it'll work
just like any other show the reason it's
only 13 episodes is so that they don't
have to spend quite as much money and so
that it's easier to shoot around actor
schedules one of the big problems with
air on the flash getting actors is
especially big actors on an ongoing
basis is that they film over a hundred
and eighty days a year that can make it
impossible to work around people's
schedules that's why you don't see
Stephen Amell in as many big movies he's
just started to do that now because it's
really hard to shoot when you only have
like six or eight weeks off I mean that
probably won't announce a season two
till after its run is completed next
year like around this time next year
next question say in duck asks if Oliver
isn't gonna wear his suit anymore why is
he wearing it in the trailer for legends
of tomorrow but I don't know if I
explained this before but they had to
shoot that footage for advertisers to
sell the show and they hadn't made up
their minds on on like how things were
gonna work especially with the
conclusion of arrow season 3 in the
flash season 1 think of that moment on
the roof as like the Fight Club promo a
lot of people thought that that Fight
Club thing was an actual show it's not
that was just like a fun thing to
promote the show's next question Bentley
asks I've never seen Smallville is it
worth watching if I enjoy the flash and
arrow well you know I mean it's a fun
show but it's very different it was made
during a very different era
it also started before like the big
movie reboot of Batman and Superman
before Man of Steel even before the
Christopher Nolan Batman films there was
a little bit of overlap but it was just
like you know the core operating mission
of the characters you know had
fundamentally changed by the time the
Christopher Nolan movies came along
everything got really realistic really
dark really gritty so now there's like a
certain expectation that the TV shows
reflect that and I you know I think
they're starting to a little bit TV
still tends to be a little bit lighter
but Smallville is like super whimsical
with the way it treats its stories so if
you like really campy jokes and you can
get around some of the contrived
situations just you know based on
Superman's abilities then yeah it's a
totally fun show thank you everyone for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do and again you know I can't
make any official Supergirl pilot videos
until they release it officially I will
do some Supergirl bonus videos though
and you're free to comment just please
don't including they like file sharing
links in the comments and use spoiler
tags you're gonna be talking about
Supergirl stuff I think what I might do
for my next bonus video is try to
explain the DC multiverse and how the TV
shows might treat that so be sure to
subscribe to get that there's a whole
bunch of character videos that I like to
do for all the shows and a lot of you
been asking if I'm gonna do any summer
TV shows like stuff that's gonna
premiere during the summer there are a
couple I'll do a separate video
explaining that because Walking Dead
Doctor Who and Jonathan strange and Mr
Norrell will all premiere during the
summer so while you guys wait for that
in case you haven't seen it you can
click here for my arrow season 4
predictions and you can click here for
my flash season 2 predictions thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight